So, before we continue with this project, I want
to highlight a few new words that we have used
in the code thus far. We've identified turtle as
a class. And brad and angie as instances of that
class. Now, I want to take a moment and
talk about these new words. You can think of a
class as a blueprint of a building. Now, a
blueprint as we know, contains certain pieces of information about
the building. For instance, the height of the
building, the number of rooms in the building. We
also know that the same blueprint can be used
to build multiple different buildings. For instance, an office
with yellow walls, and a residential complex with blue
walls. A class is like a blueprint. So let's
take the example of class Turtle that we've used
thus far. A class Turtle, much like a blueprint,
contains certain pieces of information about the turtle.
The turtle's size, its color, the fact that the
turtle can move forward and turn right. And from
this class, or blueprint we can create multiple different
instances of that class. For example, Brad is
an instance of class Turtle that draws a yellow
square, and Angie is also an instance of class
Turtle that draws a blue circle. So, in summation,
you can think of a class as a blueprint, and you
can think of its objects as example or instances of that blueprint.